- Thank you to Skillshare
for being the sponsor of this video.
One of the topics that I'm really
passionate about is slide writing,
and slide writing is
the science or the art
of creating slide presentations
in the style of leading
consulting firms like MBB,
and this is McKinsey, BCG, and Bain.
As you probably already know
if you're a regular watcher
of this channel I worked
at McKinsey for six years,
I taught slide writing inside
the firms to junior colleagues
but I'm also giving
trainings on slide writing
to corporations and
also serve as a lecturer
on communication and
slide writing for instance
at the University of
Zangala and MBA programs.
So today I will help you to build
your slide writing skills as well.
And I'll do this by reviewing
slide presentations that you sent me.
So I said in Instagram to send me some
of the documents that you're working on
for instance on university projects
and I received several
submissions from you.
So we're going to look
into this in a moment,
but before we do that
I just wanna be really clear on one thing.
So maybe some of you are asking yourselves
now where did all my hair go?
And due to the special
situation in Germany
all the hair dressers
are closed at the moment.
So no, I did not bribe any
professional to cut my hair,
I just asked my sister to do it.
And if you'll follow me on Instagram
you know exactly what happens.
And you also know why this
may be was not the best idea,
but let's not talk more
about this right now.
Welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel "Firm Learning"
it's already pretty late here in Germany,
So I'm drinking tea.
Please help yourself to a cup as well.
But now without further
ado, let's jump in.
So I'm looking now at the screen
in front of me where open several
of the presentations that you sent me,
sort of course we won't go over
every presentation slide by slide
but I always selected a couple of slides
that I believe will be most
educational to discuss.
So just bear with me
a trust there are some
very important and valuable
slide writing lessons,
but really not jointly identify and find
by looking at these pages.
And here at sub this one this seems
to be some type of university presentation
about an economics class,
"The Turkish growth miracles."
So frankly I've have no
idea about the topic.
So let's just look at this page.
What do we see here?
So my first impression
is that this page looks kind of messy
but of course the question
is why does it look messy?
What makes this page look messy?
And if you look into this
probably the main reason
is that this page uses all
kinds of different font sizes.
And this is really a problem
that you see quite often.
So let's look,
here of course the section title 28,
here this title 24, red
curve depreciation 18,
this one 20 this one 18, 18
here in the chart 12,
but here also in the chart 18,
that's really all over the place.
And I believe this
really significantly adds
to this unclean, to this
reared and organized look.
So the key rule that you always wanna when
doing these types of presentations,
that the body of your slides,
so everything except for the
tittle maybe some footnotes,
should be the same font size.
So now let's look at the chart
let's look at how this chart is created.
And the first thing that pops into my eye
are these very thick dotted lines.
So usually if you make dotted lines
you don't want them to be so dominant.
You want them to be light
and in the background.
But here because these are one
of the thickest lines in this chart,
they are very dominant.
And this just doesn't look right.
And next this here the different colors.
So this is a green line,
a red line, a blue line,
the general rule
is that whenever you
use colors on your page,
it either has a direct meaning
or there needs to be alleged.
And again this will look cleaner,
nicer, more sophisticated.
My last comment is just switching here
between these two slides.
So what you see here is
that several elements
are jittering are moving.
This is also something you wanna avoid.
So you let's look at the action title
you see this is moving,
this means that this isn't
nicely improperly aligned.
And of course, this will
be noticed if you save this
as a PDF or whatever and
you just scroll through it,
and you see all these elements
moving from page to page
this just looks not
aligned, not professional.
The same of course,
you're also with the text
with these bullets and same
thing here with the footer.
Why is this moving again?
Make sure that you have
no jeering on the pages,
this just looks unprofessional.
Next presentation,
so this is apparently a
deck about Rockefeller.
So some information some facts on him.
And him first impression
is that this does already
look a bit more organized
a bit more clean than the
slides that we saw before.
And if you look at this,
you can see some goods
slide writing principles
followed here.
And if you're more interested in that
because I cannot not go into
an everyday piece of that,
actually created a whole
course on slide writing
on how to create PowerPoint presentations
in the style of leading consulting firms.
So if you're interested to that
and one of the more check out the links
in the video description
I've over 10,000 students
taking the course
that trusted might be
interesting for some of you.
Now I wanna focus on this specific page
and again it looks not too bad,
sometimes a proper action tittle
or the text here is of the same text size.
One thing that you could do to further
improve is add separate aligns.
So for some reason this still looks
a bit unfinished to me,
it seems like something is
missing you're on this page.
And I believe one thing
is these separate aligns
that you could include
between these elements to make
it look a bit more organized.
Then the next question is also,
so what exactly is this?
So these elements that are introduced here
what elements are these exactly?
What am I looking at right now?
What is the title
or the organizing principle
of these elements.
So if I understand this
correctly also from inferring
it from the action title,
this is probably something
like the competitive advantages
that Rockefeller had or
the things that he did
the measures that he undertook
to increase its market share.
And if this is what it is
then also add this asset
it's subtitled here just
to make it more clean.
And next one let's look at the chart.
And again, here basic slide
writing principles are followed.
The one thing that I wanna
give you as a general tip
and this is that whenever
you use percentages,
always add the percentage
of what are you looking at.
The percentage of what one question
that you could potentially ask yourself
when you look at the market share
is that whether this is the
market share measured in units,
or the market share measured in US dollar.
So this year just remains unclear
and this could be easily fixed just
by making yourself a habit
of always writing percentage
of what solve the market and
units or the market in dollars.
So let's move to the next presentation.
This looks like some type of
business pitch of a product
which seems to be a chair that
is included in a backpack.
So, interesting idea for sure.
Again, let's just pick one slide
to this one to just focus on this.
And this apparently is the page
in this document where the market
and industry for this product
is supposed to be explained.
So you're the first thing that you see
is that it's really hard to
understand what the message
of all of this really supposed to be.
What is not really the thing
that I should take away from this page.
And here the clearest
thing that is missing
is the action title.
So you see the titles
just market and industry.
This is pretty much just a header,
but a clear action title is missing.
And this is exactly why
it's just super difficult
to really understand what the messages is.
You have no idea what I'm talking about
if you don't know what an action title is,
then check out my video
that I made specifically on action titles
where I explain what it's all about.
Action titles are a fundamental piece
of every slide presentation,
check out the video here
to know more about it
about it's customs in the past.
And now if you look into this,
you'll see again different font sizes use.
This is font 20, this is font 18.
Of course, this here is something
that you can barely read.
Neither general rule is especially
for professional presentations,
never just copy paste charts like that,
but especially if you
already have the numbers
as they already apparently present here,
just recreate the chart in PowerPoint.
It will always look much
better and much cleaner
but here's so much remains in the doc
so pains of the industry,
what industry exactly are
you talking about here?
So this the sports and outdoor market?
Is this the industry?
as far as I can see this
was also not properly
introduced on the pages before.
So really hard to understand
same thing here for this shot.
So what exactly is this
chart supposed to tell me.
So understand that here
below the some type
of market sizing for
the Portuguese market,
but here this chart has
used penetration worldwide.
So the user penetration of what?
And here as far as I understand Portugal
seems to have a rather low
to medium user penetration.
So what does this mean?
Is this good?
Is this bad?
So again, I really have
no idea what this page
is supposed to tell me
or what I'm supposed to
take out of this page.
So our next presentation,
this is a set of slides
that apparently talk about networking.
And overall I must say
they look professional,
they look very well done.
One thing that I just
want to put your attention
is that on a page like that,
there's just lots of texts.
And in almost all situations
people will never read this much text.
Even if they get this handled as a report
or handled as a business presentation,
this is just something
that will not be read.
And what you could easily do here
is just to divert the whole page.
So take out lots of words
by keeping the full meaning
of what you see here
because indeed your
full sentences are used
as if you would read a book
through on these slide presentations
so usually wanna say as much as possible
with as little words as possible
just to declutter to divert it.
And the main way to do
this is of course rather
use bullet point style
instead of full sentences.
So just one little example,
instead of writing the value
of this information depends on
the trust within the network.
Just write a bullet saying information
value depends on network trust.
So one little thing that you can
often do to take out words
is to delete articles
like the to deword the page.
And indeed another way to
improve your communication
and business skills is to take classes
on a platform like Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people.
You can explore news skills,
deepen your passions and
get lost in creativity.
There are classes on marketing,
personal branding, presentations
skills and many more.
All of these are topics
that are highly applicable
to a career in consulting
banking or corporate.
And the best thing is that I made
a slide writing class for Skillshare.
So you can access and enjoy
it as a Skillshare member.
Personally recently taught the class
productivity master class principles
and tools to boost your productivity
from the fellow YouTuber Ali Abdaal.
It's a great class it
taught me many new aspects
of productivity in a very much enjoyed
how you applied the peritoneal principle
or the 80 20 rule to productivity.
Classes on Skillshare are
specifically curated for learning.
There are no ads,
they're always launching
new premium classes
so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your
creativity takes you.
And the best thing is that it's less
than $10 a month with
an annual subscription.
Skillshare created a special offer
for subscribers of this
channel "Firm Learning."
And so the first thousand subscribers
of me that click on this case
link in the video description
we get a free trial
of the Skilshare premium membership.
I hope this helps you to
explore your creativity
check out our link individual description.
So now to the next presentation,
and here the one thing
that I wanna point out
is how too much graphical things,
how too many animations
can really take away
from the content of the slides
and can even also look
unprofessional to some extent.
So here if you go over there
are so many animations,
so many colors that do not really add much
to the actual content
with the actual meaning.
That the things that you actually
wanna say with your slides
get completely diminished.
So here just be sure that
you use graphical elements
like this and bold colors
like this very selectively
usually less is more, and
the same is true animations.
Usually there are no animations
and presentations like this.
One of the reasons being that often
these presentations are
not even getting presented,
but they're just printed out as documents.
And then you just go over
these documents in a meeting
and everybody just has a handout
of this presentation document
in front of him or her.
But even if you are
presenting it on a display,
animations is just not the look fear
that you should go for
four C level presentations.
It will be perceived as unprofessional.
This is just not what is expected
from you in these environments.
So now next one and again
this seems to be from
a university project.
And the reason why I included this
is just because I wanted to show
you the bit different type of style,
that this presentation is using.
This is a presentation style
that you will see more
frequently in banking.
So in most consulting context,
pages like that would never
go into the main deck.
It just far too much texts,
things like this would go in the backup
but for whatever reason bank has just like
to put even more words
in the presentations than consultance,
but this is indeed what you
will find a if you join a bank.
And just wanna also make you
aware of one other speciality
that you'll often find in
these banking presentations.
And this is the so-called
footboy fear chart.
And this is exactly what you see here,
bankers use this all the time to display
spreads and company valuations coming
from different valuation types.
Well, the problem is nobody
understands this outside of banking.
I tried to make charts
like this several time
in a consulting context.
And I've yet to meet a client
that can understand and
read this type of chart.
So my takeaway here is that
there are some differences
in consulting compared
to banking presentations,
though I would argue if you wanna learn
the presentation style,
that will make you successful
in C-level environments
in boardroom environments
of large corporate firms,
then I would argue that the
conservative style probably
will be a bit more successful for you.
This is at least from my
experience what works much better
if you wanna communicate your
insights to your leadership
in most business situations
and environments.
So hope you found this helpful.
And I wanna say a big
thank you to everybody
who volunteered to send me
their presentations here
for review in this video.
This of course is much appreciated
and I hope that there were some learnings
for many of you out there,
but of course I also wanna be clear
that there is no such thing,
as the law of slide presentations.
So after all everything that I said
to you is from my personal opinion,
of course if you ask other people
they might have a different opinion.
And of course, if you see
something differently,
very happy to discuss this with you,
just leave me a comment
below in the comment section
very happy to interact here with you
and also to learn from you
from your perspective
and your experiences.
Now, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And also subscribe to the channel to stay
up the date on all the content.
If you want to see even more from me
follow your main Instagram
my handle is firmlearning.
I also have a mailing list,
you can sign up via the link
in the video description.
Thanks again, to Skillshare
being the sponsor of this video.
There is a link to Skillshare
in the video description,
I can only encourage you to make use
of the free trial that is provided there.
In addition to that as always of course,
a big thank you to all the members
of Firm Learning as well,
you are the OGs you're really supporting
here the cause on Firm Learning,
so thank you so much.
My name is Heinrich,
I'm releasing videos every single week
on Saturday here on my
channel "Firm Learning."
So looking forward to
see you again next week
until then good weekend to all of you,
keep learning, cheers, Heinrich here.